I've shown you some graphs that suggest
the ways the models can fit the data,
more or less closely.
But let's have a more formal
definition of this matching.
It's called error.
A standard way to measure error,
is called RMS error.
Let me show you how to calculate this.
Let's suppose we use this data,
which are these green points,
to build a model.
Let's say it's a linear model like this.
We can assess the model
at each real data point.
For instance, at this data point.
And measure the difference between the Y
value of the data point, and the model.
And this difference is error.
Now, we've got an error at every
single one of these data points.
And what we do to measure
root mean squared error,
is to take the error at each
one of these points, square it,
add them together, take the average,
and take the square root of that.
So that sounds kind of complicated,
but here's what it looks like.
Ytest minus Ypredict.
So Ytest are the actual
values of the data.
Ypredict are what our model predicted.
We take that difference at each point.
That's this difference.
Square it, sum all those together,
divide by the number of points and
take the square root.
And that's our root mean squared error.
And what this is
an approximation of really,
is sort of the average error here.
But we end up emphasizing
larger errors a bit more.